-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
Today was Thanksgiving, the day
we all sit around the table
and think, "Which of these
cousins has weed?"
President Biden
and his family spent
Thanksgiving on Nantucket
at the $39 million home
of private-equity
billionaire David Rubenstein.
And even there, they won't
have enough normal chairs
for everybody.
Today was the
Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade,
which featured
12 marching bands.
Though the moment New Yorkers
saw them take out instruments,
they all instinctively
put in AirPods.
That's right, today was the
Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade,
which featured
16 giant character balloons,
700 clowns,
and one very lost marathoner.
New York Mayor Adams made
a safety announcement yesterday
for the Thanksgiving Day Parade,
where he assured New Yorkers
that everything was perfectly
safe, except his job.
Target is offering a full
Thanksgiving meal for $25,
including a 10-pound turkey,
potatoes, stuffing mix,
gravy, and cranberry sauce.
The way it works is,
you go to the self-checkout
and only scan the potatoes.
According to new research,
belly fat may be linked
to early stages
of Alzheimer's disease.
So now he's making a list and
checking it three, four times.
"I think I've been to
this house."
And, finally, according to AAA,
more than 55 million people
are expected to travel
over the Thanksgiving holiday,
even though more than
100 million bought tickets.
And that was a monologue,
everybody.
We are very excited
to have you here tonight.